I will be the President of 85 million people. I
say this everywhere, whether they vote or not,
I have to reconcile Turkey. We
want to be a part of the civilized world of the West. We want democracy in our country, we do
not want an authoritarian government and we
want freedom. Young people and
women suffer greatly, they
also want freedom. Therefore, we are the
European Union.  We will bring all the
democratic rules envisaged by to our own country.
[Music] I
have never seen a second person in my life who lies as much as him. He
distorts the facts and makes all kinds of smears,
but no matter what he does, the people's
choice will be on my side.